when you or i want to borrow money we'd
go to a bank and put up our home or
something valuable as collateral when
the world's richest people want to
borrow money they can put up or pledge
some of their shares in public companies
as collateral for lines of credit
instead of selling shares and paying
capital gains taxes
pledging shares is when an individual
puts up their stake in a public company
as collateral to take on personal lines
of credit that debt can be for any
number of reasons whether it's buying
real estate investing in other companies
or even buying more stock of the share
that's being pledged
the benefits for pledging are pretty
straightforward it allows shareholders
to access cash while preserving their
power within a company and avoiding
capital gains taxes
since 2006 the sec has required all
public companies to disclose pledge
shares of executive officers directors
or individuals who hold more than five
percent of a company's outstanding stock
it's also important to note here that
billionaires are doing the majority of
share pledging at least in terms of
value there are currently 560 executive
officers directors and 5 plus
shareholders who are currently pledging
shares but just 32 members of the forbes
400 list of richest americans account
for the vast majority of the aggregate
value of all pledge shares in the market
tesla ceo elon musk is the richest and
most famous pledger of company shares
but i think the more revealing and
interesting example is actually larry
ellison the oracle co-founder who boasts
a fortune of over 100 billion dollars
ellison has been pledging his oracle
shares to take on debt for at least two
decades in 2018 oracle's board of
directors started prohibiting share
pledging but ellison the only oracle
employee to ever report pledging shares
was also the only individual exempted
from the new company policy for critics
of billionaire borrowing ellison is
something of an ideal case study the
billionaire has seemingly used pledging
to finance his real estate spending
spree including an estimated 300 million
dollars on the hawaiian island of lanai
while preserving his power at oracle
more than two-thirds of s p 500
companies ban all company employees and
shareholders from pledging shares for
debt 22 prohibit pledging but with
exemptions for certain individuals and
only 3.4 percent fully permitted share
pledging is a corporate governance issue
it's something that outside shareholders
and institutional investors frown upon
the larger the company the more likely
they are to attract sophisticated
institutional investors who have certain
expectations on corporate governance
matters like pledging they say that
pledging creates a misalignment of
incentives
between shareholders the idea here is
that pledgers by diversifying their
wealth through debt-financed investments
are essentially reducing their immediate
economic interest in a company's success
the bigger risk though is that pledgers
face margin calls against loans they've
taken out if the price of a pledge stock
falls a lender may demand the borrower
put up more collateral to secure a loan
if a pledger isn't liquid enough to do
that then they may have to sell a
significant amount of the company's
stock being pledged which can put
further downward pressure on the share
price and generate more anxiety amongst
outside shareholders
margin calls against pledge shares can
risk spiraling into a domino-like effect
on the stock many companies don't make
arguments against pledging but defenders
of the practice including tesla argue
pledging creates a fiduciary
relationship between pledgers and
shareholders in 2018 the electric car
maker argued that pledging gives quote
executive officers flexibility in
financial planning without having to
rely on large cash compensation or the
sale of company shares thus keeping
their interest well aligned with those
of our stockholders while also
mitigating risk exposure to the company
when we talk about share pledging we
have to keep in mind that it is a
limited slice of the
overall pie
of
assets that are being pledged for debt
in the market
and when it comes to the world of
billionaire borrowing there's still a
lot we don't know individuals who
collateralize private stakes or
diversified baskets of securities for
which they're not serving as a director
or executive officer
we don't have information on those
pledges and the debt that's being taken
out against those pledges so while
pledge shares
offer a window onto the world of
billionaire borrowing um it's still a
pretty murky world
and there's a lot we don't know
[Music]